>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome back
Vic Gundotra.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Well, good morning.
Welcome, everybody.
It's great to see this room jam-packed so
early in the morning. I hope you guys had
a great time yesterday and a good time at
the party last night.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, it wasn't just us
that had a great time yesterday. We had over
60,000 simultaneous viewers watch our show.
That's pretty staggering. Because it is a
global audience, throughout the day, that
number increased, and total viewers yesterday
was just topping out over 600,000 people.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And so --
>>Vic Gundotra: -- we can't thank you all
enough for the global enthusiasm that you've
expressed for the hard work that we're doing.
It's very, very gratifying.
I hope all of you also enjoyed your Samsung
tablets.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Are these great or what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: One thing you might have missed
was that, in addition to getting this tablet,
you also received this voucher. This voucher
we will actually deliver on today at 3:30.
And what you'll get is one of these. This
is just absolutely amazing. It's a Verizon
Wi-Fi hot spot, provided through our partnership
with Verizon and Samsung. On typical 4G areas,
you'll get up to 20 megabits per second down,
ten megabits per second up. Typical areas
do not include this room.
But I got about seven megabits down a few
moments ago in the room. But like we said,
please turn off your Wi-Fi hot spots for the
sake of the presentation.
But I hope you enjoy this as well. This is
really, really great. Thank you to Verizon
and Samsung for that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's turn our attention to
the keynote this morning.
You know, from its very inception, this show
has always been about the most important platform
of our era. It's a platform that's controlled
by none of us, so it's the only platform that
truly belongs to all of us. And that is the
open Web. And the Chrome team has set the
pace of moving the Web forward along the dimensions
of speed, along the dimensions of security,
and along the dimensions of capability.
To hear what's next in the incredibly exciting
story of Chrome, I'd like to introduce my
friend and senior vice president of Chrome,
Sundar Pichai.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you. It's very exciting
to be here.
Welcome to the Chrome keynote.
We have a lot to cover. We are here to talk
about the open Web, the amazing platform it
is, the pace at which it's making progress.
Chrome is the way we manifest the Web to our
users. So we want to give you an update on
Chrome, Chrome Web Store, and finally Chrome
OS. Lots to cover. Let's get started.
Exactly a year ago, at Google I/O, we were
here on this stage. We were incredibly excited
at the momentum behind Chrome. We announced
that over 70 million active users were using
Chrome as their main browser. So it's been
a year since then. And we are back at I/O.
So let's take a look at where we are now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So we have more than doubled
in the last year. And we couldn't be more
pleased.
Many of you in this audience were some of
the earliest adopters of Chrome and helped
get the word around. So thank you.
If -- let's take a look at what's happened
since last I/O to now, within the last year.
So let's zoom in between the 70 to 160 million.
If you take a look, it's actually a bit tough
to remember, but last year, we were at Chrome
4. So we had just launched the stable version
of Chrome 4. And if you remember, it was available
only for Windows. We didn't have Mac and Linux
versions. In fact, that's what most of the
team was working on, getting Chrome to be
an equal citizen on the two other great platforms.
It was a lot of work. It consumed a lot of
resources. And with Chrome 6, we brought Chrome
to the Mac and Linux stable channel.
At that point, we made an important decision
as a team. We decided to switch to six-week
release cycles. We wanted to make sure version
numbers shouldn't matter, that we continually
push features out, both to users, and more
importantly, to developers, as and when HTML5
APIs became ready.
So let's take a look.
As you can see, in the last 12 months, we've
been releasing every six weeks. And this week,
we just launched Chrome 12 in beta. So we've
had our eight versions of Chrome just in the
last year alone. The pace at which we are
pushing the Web platform forward is amazing.
There are a whole slough of APIs here. We'll
talk about them in more detail.
But we have focused on many other things as
well. Speed is something near and dear to
our heart. We have had over 20X speed and
JavaScript improvement last year alone. We
have pushed security really hard. Chrome has
a great sandbox. In addition, last year for
the first time, we have sandbox plug-ins.
PDF is fully sandboxed, and Flash is partially
sandboxed, and we are working on completing
the sandbox. So the progress has been great.
The good news is, we are not the only ones
pushing the platform forward. All browser
vendors, modern browsers, are investing in
HTML5. So if you take a look at 2008, this
was just under way. Chrome had launched. People
were beginning to add HTML5 APIs. We spoke
about it in I/O. And if you forward to now,
the progress is amazing. All modern browsers
have these APIs implemented, so that you as
developers can rely on these APIs when you
write applications and make sure you can deliver
a consistent experience.
So let's take a look at some of the upcoming
APIs which we are excited about in Chrome.
To do that, I want to invite Ian Ellison-Taylor,
who's the director of the Web Platform team
in Chrome.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: It's a long way up.
Thanks, everybody.
What Sundar showed on an earlier slide, there's
been an amazing number of new features added
to the Web platform just over the last year
alone. And I think taken together, they add
up to an amazing new set of capabilities for
Web applications running in modern browsers.
I think it's amazing the kinds of things that
you can build today.
Now, of course, we're not resting on our laurels
at Google, and with hundreds, literally hundreds,
of other collaborators, new features are being
added all the time. It's a genuine community
effort on everyone's part.
So I wanted to take a minute or two today
and just run you through some of those features.
And I'm going to start with I think one of
my favorite features, one of the new and cool
features, and that's speech.
So let me run through that here. I can give
you a quick demo.
So for the purposes of the demo, I'm going
to use this application that's a fantastic
application from the Web Store. It's called
Clicker. It lets you discover and view some
of the best online Web video. So imagine for
a second I'm an engineer at Clicker, and I
want to add speech to this.
So here's the little search panel inside Clicker.
And I want to add some speech support.
So there's lots of ways to do it. One of the
easiest ways just to try things out is to
use the developer tools that are built into
Chrome.
So I'm going to right-click on inspect element.
And then this brings up the developer tools
that you can see in the bottom panel.
Now, the developer tools in Chrome have come
a really long way in the last year or so.
I think many of these features, I think, are
state of the art. So I very much encourage
you to check out the developer tools session
a little bit later.
I'm just going to focus on a couple of quick
features here. So I'm just going to right-click
and add attribute. And I'm going to add the
X-Webkit -- oops -- how about if I type properly
-- speech attribute. And I can close the dev
tools.
And so sort of as if by magic, there's -- a
little microphone appeared. Now, I haven't
done anything else. I haven't added any event
handlers or written any code. I just added
that one attribute to this application. It
wasn't originally designed with speech in
mind. That's adding the attribute.
Let's give it a try and see if this works.
Now, I should caveat that one of the first
rules of keynotes is never, ever do live speech
demos. The acoustics in the room make it really
hard. But we're going to try anyway. And I
figure if it goes absolutely horribly wrong,
it will at least be entertaining. So let's
see what happens.
So one of my favorite shows right now is called
bandwagon. It stars Emma Caufield from Buffy
and a host of other movies. I'm going to search
for that and see what happens. Let's try this.
Emma Caufield.
Oh, it works. My gosh. That's -- you have
no idea --
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: -- how -- I am genuinely
surprised.
I'm genuinely surprised that works. And here's
Bandwagon, the show. And I can click through
and watch it very quickly.
Let's close that.
So that's fantastic, it did well with my bizarre
English, slash, American accent.
So as you can imagine, at Google, we're adding
speech support to a lot of our applications
as well. What I want to show you quickly and
one of my favorites is translate. This is
something -- I like showing this because I
genuinely need this. I am terrible at foreign
languages. And so this is a great -- it's
a great way to do quick translation. And you
can try this out.
I'm going to do -- I'm going to do a translation
from English into Chinese. I think Chinese
is the language I am least likely to learn
in the future. So this is a good test.
Like I said, this has already been modified,
so it has the little microphone icon down
here.
Welcome to San Francisco.
It works. Amazing.
All right. So it's -- it's taken the speech,
translated to Chinese. We can listen to this
now. (Chinese).
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: One more time. (Chinese).
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: So I don't actually
speak Chinese. So I have no idea if that was
actually correct. Does anyone -- people are
nodding. Yes, all right.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: I was afraid there for
a second I was going to insult someone's mother.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: But I think we did okay.
All right. So that's, just quickly, speech.
New features are fantastic, of course. But
performance is a feature, too.
And making things fast has been one of the
sort of fundamental founding criteria of Chrome
since the very early days.
So you can see behind me, this is a little
chart of JavaScript performance. And back
in -- this is back in 2008 -- and this is
the best of. This isn't just Chrome. This
is what was the state of the art of JavaScript
back in the day. And if you look at what's
happened since then up to Chrome 11, the progress
on JavaScript has been truly phenomenal. It's
fundamentally changed the kinds of applications
you can build on the Web.
And, you know, in some respects, I'm kind
of hoping I never share this chart again.
We're going to continue to work on JavaScript
performance, of course. But the good news
here is, really, it's no longer the bottleneck
that it used to be. And so we're beginning
to focus more of our attention on some of
the areas -- other areas of the Web platform,
where there are more opportunities to make
performance improvements.
Now, one of those areas, one of the key areas
is, of course, graphics. And, specifically,
GPU acceleration, using the GPU to hardware-accelerate
graphics and get the best out of the performance
of your modern laptop as well as improve battery
life.
One of the easiest ways to do that is using
CSS transforms. I know many of you will have
been using CSS for a while now. It's super
easy to do. And it's in beta right now in
Chrome, where those are now GPU-accelerated.
So you don't have to do anything to your applications.
Just keep using CSS and things will just get
magically faster.
CSS is great.
Now, a level up in terms of capability is
Canvas 2D. Canvas 2D is particularly important,
because it's used for a lot of games. And
in games, one of the most common operations
that you want to do and have be fast is sprite
animation, moving lots of little images or
animated characters zipping around.
So that's one of the areas that we've been
focusing on heavily in the latest releases
of Chrome.
So I'm going to give you a quick demo of what
that looks like in Chrome.
So for the purposes of the demo, I'm going
to use the famous, some would say infamous,
fishy demo, courtesy of Microsoft.
So this is Chrome, running in software. It
does pretty well with 20 fish. But if you
go up to, say, like, 100 or let's go to 500,
you can see there the frame rate's dropping.
We're under ten frames a second.
So here is a new version of Chrome with GPU
acceleration turned on for the canvas. You
can see here at 100 frames a second, 100 fish,
still doing 60 frames a second.
Go up to 250. Keep going. 500.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Thank you, thank you.
You can applause.
It's not until we get to 1,000 fish where
you start to see it going below 60 frames
per second. So that's basically a 10x improvement
over where we were. So I think that's phenomenal.
And again, you didn't have to do anything.
Things just got faster. So definitely try
out Canvas 2D. I think that's phenomenal.
But wait, there's more!
So doing this kind of sprite animation is
actually something that WebGL is extremely
good at doing.
So our friends at Mozilla actually took the
fishy demo and ported it over to use WebGL.
So let's look at a thousand fish straight
away. Let's just jump to that.
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: So that's too easy.
2,000. Still too easy.
10,000. All right.
So now we are up to 10,000 or so Sprites and
still doing around 30 frames per second.
So this is another 10x performance improvement,
and it's very easy to move that kind of sprite
animation over to WebGL.
It's a fantastic way to take advantage of
the performance of a modern laptop. I think
this is pretty phenomenal.
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Yes, authentication.
Applause, applause.
So do definitely give that a try.
Now, WebGL can be used for lots of things.
It's not just good for sprite animation. It
is full 3D. So just briefly, I wanted to show
an example of sort of a more traditional 3D
application.
So this is Tinkercad that lets you do a little
bit of design on a surface here, and I am
just going to quickly draw some shapes. And
I have to apologize for not being a designer,
and, you know, not having any artistic ability
whatsoever. But I can build a little model
surface and I can quickly punch holes in the
surface. Let's do that. So I can do some solid
geometry modeling. This is running in the
browser, and I am zoom in and out. And the
performance of this is absolutely fantastic.
I didn't have to install any plug-ins. This
is just using the inherent 3D support that's
in the browser now.
So I think this is pretty cool. And Tinkercad
in particular I think is fantastic. You should
try this out because it lets you export these
3D models and send them to a 3D printer. So
you can actually build the things that you
design, which I think is absolutely phenomenal.
So that's it for WebGL and some features.
So those are great features, and of course
there's going to be lots more to come. There's
hundreds of features coming in a build near
you. So stay tuned for upcoming releases.
And with that, I thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Ian.
Speed is the fundamental underpinning behind
Chrome, and I think these GP acceleration
improvements is going to make Chrome much
faster.
In fact, for example, if you were writing
a game about six months ago and you were writing
it in canvas and software, and if you can
now write it in WebGL, GP accelerated, it's
going to be about 100 times faster. So that's
the pace at which the Web is evolving.
Of course writing these applications only
matter if you can reach users, which is why
about three months ago in the stable channel
of the U.S. we launched the Chrome Web Store.
The goal behind the Web Store was to help
developers reach users and monetize their
applications.
In the first three months since we have launched,
we have had amazing early traction. We have
had over 17 million applications installed,
and more importantly, developers have informed
us that people spend a lot more time in their
application when they install it from the
Chrome Web Store.
To give you some examples, roughly we see
about a 2x increase in the amount of time
spent per app when installed from the Web
Store. Springpad, which is a productivity
application, has noticed this increase, and
so have many others. And games. Games have
seen about two and a half times increase in
transactions when users have installed a game
in the Web Store.
So we are taking the Web Store and as of today
we are making it available in 41 languages
to all 160 million users of Chrome.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: We are very excited that
you as developers can write an application
and reach the entire install base of Chrome.
When you write these applications there are
two aspects of it. The first is reach, so
we want to make sure you can reach all users
of Chrome, but more importantly we want to
make sure you can monetize your applications.
This is why when we launched Chrome Web Store
we offered the ability for you to charge for
your applications. But we want to constantly
explore more options by which developers can
monetize. One of the problems on the Web today,
it's very tough to charge users in context
within your application without breaking the
flow. So we want to create a seamless payment
experience for developers and users alike.
To talk about that, let me invite Vikas Gupta,
product manager on the Google Payments Team.
[ Applause ]
>>Vikas Gupta: Thank you, Sundar. Hello, everyone.
I am tremendously excited to be here today
to talk about in-app payments. In some ways,
it's the culmination of a vision that our
team has been working on for the past few
years. It started with the basic idea that
we can make purchases within applications
extremely frictionless, extremely seamless
so users who are engaged in your applications
can stay engaged while they make a purchase.
It should be really easy for developers to
implement it, and should be just as secure
and reliable as every online purchase should
be.
What's even more exciting for us today is
that we're delivering that vision at Google
scale. That means you can take this and take
it to users everywhere on the Web.
Let me show you a little bit of how it works.
This is an application built by Graphic.ly.
It's available in the Web Store. It let's
you discover, browse, read and enjoy comic
books and graphic novels on the Web. It's
a great, fun experience, and I highly encourage
all of to you to go check it out.
One of the things that Graphic.ly wanted do
is let users start reading the comic book
before they made a purchase. And once a sure
starts enjoying it, starts getting hooked,
that's when you give them the option to actually
make a purchase within there.
It's now possible with our API. And it's really
simple. With a single click, the user can
initiate the purchase, and with another click,
complete and go back to reading the comic
book they were originally enjoying.
That's it. That's all it takes for a user
to make a purchase within the application.
Let me show you how it works.
Just like we wanted to make it really easy
for users to make knows purchases, we also
wanted to make it stunningly simple for developers
to implement it.
All it takes for you to implement this is
a single line of code. There's one line of
code that integrates it and lets initiate
the purchase flow where the users can go make
a purchase. And once the purchase is complete,
you get a call back that you can take a new
application and deliver the goods with a single
line of code.
That's all it is.
And the session later today we will talk about
this platform and API in a lot more detail
and I highly encourage you to go and check
that out.
There's one more thing. We wanted to make
it simple for users, we wanted to make it
simple for developers to implement it, but
we also wanted to figure out, how do we price
it so that all of you can build amazing businesses
on this platform.
When we looked around, we found that applications
tend to pay very complicated set of fees.
There are setup fees, there are minimum fees,
there are monthly fees, there are fixed fees.
We wanted to keep it simple.
We also found out that online applications
and social games are starting to pay to the
tune of 30% for payment fees. 30%.
We at Google felt we could do a little better,
so I am glad to announce today that this platform
that you can integrate into your applications
with a single line of code can deliver users
this amazingly stunningly simple purchase
experience and take it to everywhere on the
Web is priced at a flat fee of 5%.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Vikas Gupta: I'm sure you have done the
math but let me do the simple math for you.
Of all the money that people are spending
on applications, 95% stays with you.
We believe that's a great thing for developers
and a great thing for the Web.
[ Applause ]
>>Vikas Gupta: Thank you.
>>Sundar Pichai: Wow! For 5%, it almost wants
me to go out and write a Web application and
implement in-app payments right now.
Stow we are very excited about this feature.
We hope all of you take advantage of it, and
the ability to offer payments in context without
breaking the experience for users can be a
game changer on the Web. So we are very excited
about it.
Next we want to showcase a game for you. This
game couldn't have been on the Web a year
ago. It's available on many platforms. It's
one of the leading games in the world, but
to do that on the Web was difficult. But thanks
to the recent improvements, the great GPU
capabilities that you just saw, they have
been able for the first time to bring their
game onto the Web.
To talk about this game let me invite the
one and the only Mighty Eagle, also known
as Peter Vesterbacka from Rovio.
>>Peter Vesterbacka: Yeah, so are we ready
for some fun and games?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: Yeah. So thanks, Sundar.
It's really great to be here, and we wanted
to bring Angry Birds to the Web for a long,
long time, but you know Angry Birds, it's
a great experience on all the platforms, all
the devices that we support. So we didn't
want to compromise on the performance.
Okay, we're not making, like, fish in a bowl
or anything like that, but it's all about
Angry Birds and some really, really angry,
really angry birds.
And of course one of the reasons we have been
angry is because we haven't been able to bring
this to the Web. So it really hasn't been
possible until today.
And today, the reason I'm here is actually
because we are bringing Angry Birds to the
biggest platform out there: The Web.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: And it's really a great
version of Angry Birds. I mean, it's one of
the best that we built to date.
And it really is as fun, as engaging as any
of the versions that we have out there right
now.
But again, you know, don't take my word for
it. We actually have the real thing here,
so why don't we play some Angry Birds. Kan,
go ahead, take it away.
[ Music ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: And, Kan, if you pop
some of those pigs, clear some of those levels,
maybe we will get you one of these cool hoodies
afterwards.
[ Angry Bird sounds ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: So as you can see, this
is the Angry Birds that I'm sure you have
played for a few hours.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: And it really plays really,
really well. And, you know, on most modern
PCs, we get 60 frames per second easily. So
it really, really is a very, very smooth,
very, very nice Angry Birds experience.
And again, of course at Rovio we wouldn't
settle for anything less, so it has to be
great.
And we think that we built a really great
version here for Chrome.
And we built this using WebGL, so it really
rocks, as you can see. But if you're browser
for some reason doesn't support WebGL, we
also support canvas, so that works as well.
And if your browser supports hardware acceleration,
then you get the HD experience that you just
saw. So it looks and plays really, really
well.
But again, if you don't have hardware acceleration,
we have a fallback so you can still play the
game. It's not the perfect experience, but
it's still, like, really, really good. So
it's all there.
Another, like, really cool thing, okay, it's
browser based and all of that, so what if
you're offline?
What we have done is we use local storage.
And again, because we are in the Chrome Web
Store, we can get some extra up cache, extra
storage. So you can play the complete game
offline line.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: So again, really, really
cool. So, you know, now we'll make those flights
more bearable, so when you run out of battery
in your Android device, you can continue on
your, like, Chrome netbook and it goes on
and on.
So it works offline, and it's really fantastic.
But again, and as you probably figured by
now, so we think Chrome is a great environment
for Angry Birds, so we didn't want to stop
there.
We wanted to offer a special treat only for
the users of Chrome. And I guess we have a
few of you here in this room, I guess. Just
guessing.
Anyway, so we built something very special
for Chrome.
So we built some special exclusive levels
that are only available in Chrome.
So let's enter the Chrome dimension.
[ Laughter ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: So you see some familiar
things in there. So we have, you know, some
of these Chrome buttons as rocks. There's,
you know, some Chrome flowers, some Chrome
clouds. It's a very, like, Chrome experience.
[ Laughter ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: And we even have something
really cool. We have the Chrome bombs. So,
I mean, how cool is that?
And, yeah, I can see that Kan is -- you need
to play some more. It's clear.
But it's a new level, so I'm sure Kan would
clear the original ones easily.
It happens that you fail a level and sometimes
you can be stuck on a level for hours, even
days, weeks, I've heard. So we have a solution
for that. And really, really happy to hear
about the 5%. You know, we really love that
kind of model, you know, as a developer, you
know, that's -- that's fair.
[ Applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: So we're -- we're all
for lower taxes. And 5%, fair.
So, anyway, what we decided to do when we
heard about the 5%, we're actually going to
bring the Mighty Eagle that we actually have
been offering only on one platform so far,
we're going to bring that to Chrome.
So as soon as the in-app payments are live,
we'll be there with the Mighty Eagle that
you can buy right from your browser. And you
can use the Mighty Eagle to clear the levels.
So that will be available very, very soon
on Chrome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: And the game, it's there.
So, again, you probably are interested in
how we also deliver this.
So we use some other Google Tools. We use
the Web toolkit. So all of what you see here
was done in Java, using the Web toolkit. Actually,
it didn't take us that long to get the game
over. So it was a very smooth experience as
well.
Then we're hosting everything on App Engine.
And I've been told that it should basically
be able to cope with all of you going and
getting the game right after a keynote. So
don't worry about that. You know, feel free,
go get the game. It's available right after
this.
So really encourage you to do that.
But, yeah, I don't think that there's much
more to say. I mean, we could be here playing
Angry Birds for, like, all day. And, you know,
that's a good thing to do, and it's okay to
play, you know, like, out there. That's not
a problem at all. We actually encourage you
to play Angry Birds whenever you can.
[ Laughter ]
>>Peter Vesterbacka: But -- so, you know,
it happens.
You know, just look like you're browsing some
important files or something.
But, anyway, really happy with finally being
able to bring Angry Birds to the Web.
So after this, go get it. You know, let's
pop some pigs and play Angry Birds.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Peter.
It's been a long journey building Chrome for
over four and a half years. And I have to
say, this is the culmination point, seeing
Angry Birds finally work in Chrome. More importantly,
I think my kids will think finally I'm doing
something useful.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sundar Pichai: I'm going to be buying a
lot of Mighty Eagles.
So it's great to see a game like Angry Birds,
which couldn't have been on the Web a year
ago, running fast in full HD and very, very
smooth. That shows the pace at which the platform
is evolving.
This is what we can do on the Web today. But
there is a whole lot more you can do. The
Web is what you make of it.
To give a glimpse into the future, what the
future of the Web can be, let me invite Aaron
Koblin, from the Google Creative Lab team.
[ Applause ]
>>Aaron Koblin: Thanks a lot, Sundar.
Some of you may remember the HTML5 music project
we launched last years called The Wilderness
Downtown with the band Arcade Fire. Well,
this year, I'm really excited to give you
a sneak preview of a new interactive music
project we're working on called 3 Dreams of
Black.
So 3 Dreams of Black is an interactive music
experience which really showcases the power
of JavaScript, HTML5, and especially WebGL
to make an immersive, interactive, multimedia
3D experience for the Web.
So we worked with some amazing people. Since
this is a music experience, we teamed up with
Chris Milk, who wrote and directs the script.
It's based off some music off of Danger Mouse
and Daniel Luppe's new album called ROME,
featuring Jack White from the White Stripes
and Nora Jones.
So, basically, the experience is moving you
through a variety of dream worlds. It's involving
composited video, animation, and 3D graphics
all into one space. So I'm going to give you
a little demo of what that looks like.
So the experience starts off with some 2D
animation. It's all going with the music.
And it allows to you actually look around
and see various paralax and panorama views.
You can apply real-time shaders like I am
right here. As it goes through the story line,
it's driving through this car and it's going
to dump us there some amazing 3D interactive
worlds. I am just going to let this play through.
[ Music ]
>>Aaron Koblin: As you can see, I'm literally
painting with geometry. I'm skip ahead through
a separate section. This is going through
a prairie sequence. I'm doing collision detection,
spawning animals and separate animated elements
and interacting with the environment in realtime,
all being rendered live. You can explore these
various dream realities and kind of progress
through the story line.
Another really cool thing is, you can actually
contribute to the story line yourself. So
I'm going to skip ahead to the UGC tool. And
here you can choose what type of element you're
going to contribute to the experience. There's
a basic voxel building tool. You can begin
to build your own models right into the experiences
itself.
So we're really excited about the types of
things people are going to create with this.
I think equally exciting to the project is
actually the process behind it. So the entire
thing is open source. We released a bunch
of demos that show exactly how we put it together.
So on this tech page, you'll see some demos,
like this GLSL shader demo of hatching glow
shader. There's (inaudible) wrapping showing
how we did some of the video compositing,
depth of field. There's some really cool demos
on here, and they're all open source and you
can view the code directly within the site.
So, hopefully, you'll get a chance to take
a look at some of those.
We also built this model viewer, which allows
you to take a look at some of the assets that
are part of the project. And you can toggle
things like texture, you can do wire framing,
see how the models were built.
I'm just going to show you a couple of my
favorite models. This is a bear that morphs
into a horse.
We -- this is really my favorite. This is
a buffalo that goes into a tarantula. The
tarantalo.
You can do fun stuff like controlling the
morphing speed yourself with JavaScript and
some really cool things.
And a lot of this was built with a library
that I wanted to give a shoutout to called
three.JS. Some of you may know the developer,
Mr. Doob. And he's worked with us to build
this. Definitely recommend you check it out.
So at the bottom of the page, there's a link
to that. We're also going to put up a link
to processing.JS, which is a great starting
point for people who are interested in learning
how to use WebGL. We're going to be launching
the project really soon. You can keep your
eyes out at RO.ME is the URL.
If you're interested in checking out other
WebGL other demos, we also have a section
on Chrome experiments. So if you go to ChromeExperiments.com/WebGL,
you can see a number of these demos as well.
Thanks a lot, and talk to you soon.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Aaron.
So that's an inspiring look at how the future
of Web sites could look like. In fact, was
it a Web site? A video? A game? You get to
decide.
So we've spent the last 30 minutes talking
about the power of the Web. The pace at which
the platform is evolving and the momentum
behind Chrome.
It turns out this is what people do almost
entirely on their computers now, spend all
their time on the Web within a browser, which
is why we set out to do Chrome OS.
Let's take a brief look at what computers
look like today.
Just to spend your time on the Web within
a browser, you have to deal with all the legacy
decisions which have been made in the last
20 to 30 years in operating systems. Every
time you boot up the computer, some computers
even check to see whether there's a floppy
drive. It takes a long time to boot into your
computer. Once you're inside, you have to
make sure you manage your applications. Every
one of your applications need to be up to
date. You have to run antivirus software.
You have to back up your data. If you move
across machines or if you try to upgrade your
PC, good luck with that. It takes an entire
weekend to do so.
The experience is really, really complicated.
So we wanted to rethink the entire experience
and distill it down to nothing but the Web.
And that's what Chrome OS is.
Chrome OS can be applied to a variety of form
factors. It is just an end-to-end computing
experience, a software experience. It can
be applied to a variety of form factors. We
have chosen to focus initially on notebooks,
because that's where most of the Web usage
is there today. That's where people use the
Web the most. So we wanted to bring the Chrome
OS experience to notebooks.
When you do that, when you run Chrome OS on
notebooks, you end up with a very different,
unique experience. We call those Chromebooks.
So what makes Chromebooks different from other
notebooks? Here are a few attributes. Every
Chromebook is instant to turn on. In fact,
when you first get your device, when you unwrap
the box, you will be up and running within
three minutes.
If you're one of the 160 million active users
of Chrome, all your stuff is automatically
there with Chrome sync. Every time you boot
up, you are up and running within eight seconds.
And each time you open the lid, before you
can move your fingers and type on the keyboard,
you're connected within the Web.
We have provided built-in connectivity options,
so wherever you use them, with connectivity
options, you have data services which are
pay as you go, no contracts, no commitments.
You get free monthly usage per month, and
you can buy day passes, et cetera. So you
can be always connected.
They have all-day battery life. So I think
this is really game-changing in terms of how
you think about your notebooks. I never carry
power chargers around when I'm using a Chromebook.
It lasts all day, as long as you can charge
it at home or at the hotel at the night, you're
all set. These are some of the attributes
which make phones and tablets great as well.
But for the first time, we are bringing those
wonderful attributes of mobile computing to
the world of notebooks.
The software experience is very unique as
well. Because it is nothing but the Web, you
can access your stuff anytime, anywhere. You
can ask multiple Chromebooks, you can share
Chromebooks with people. Each time when you
open them, you get the latest and the greatest
version of the Web application which you're
using.
It gets better over time. I think this is
a concept people aren't used to on their computers.
When you buy a PC, it's great on the first
day. But as you install applications, it slowly
starts degrading over time. Because we update
Chromebooks automatically, we'll update them
every few weeks, we actually think we can
make it better over time.
To give you an example, as we have made all
the JavaScript speed improvements, your Chromebooks
will get faster. With all the GPU acceleration
improvements we talked about, you will notice
in a few months your Chromebooks are even
faster. And finally, security is built in
from the ground up.
Every piece of user data on Chromebooks, by
default, is encrypted.
Every time you boot up your computer, we take
you through a verified boot sequence to make
sure you're secure.
And, finally, you're within the Chrome sandbox.
Chrome sandbox, which is built into sandbox
Web pages and plug-ins. We think it's a pretty
unique experience.
We started testing our Chromebooks through
the Cr-48 pilot program a few months ago.
After announcing it, within the first few
weeks, we had over a million applicants. People
had to fill out long forms and submit it.
We were humbled by the interest in the program.
We have literally shipped thousands of devices
to people all over the U.S. and even internationally.
The feedback has been great. I mean, it's
open forum on the Web, so you can take a look.
People have had meetups, they've printed tee
shirts, they have been very vocal, they have
written us hundreds of e-mails.
The good news is, we've been working on many
of the same features over the last month.
We have fixed some issues we had with Cr-48.
We have completely revamped the track pad
into a much better track pad. We worked closely
with Adobe, our partner, to have a seamless
Flash experience on Chromebooks.
Intel, who powers these devices, has worked
with us to upgrade to a dual-core processor
so that Chromebooks can be much faster.
There were missing gaps when we announced
Cr-48 about six months ago. As we showed in
the event, if you plugged in a camera, nothing
happened. But it turns out now if you plug
in a camera, something interesting happens.
To show you what it is, we'll invite Kan Liu,
who is a product manager on Chrome OS.
[ Applause ]
>>Kan Liu: Thanks, Sundar. Hopefully, I'll
do better with this than I did with Angry
Birds.
I am very excited to show you guys some of
the new file features and functionality that
we've been building directly into Chrome OS.
We think it's going to make our users' lives
a lot easier. Let's start with a very common
scenario that a lot of users have. Someone
e-mails you a file and you want to be able
to save it for later viewing or use. In this
particular case, my friend has e-mailed me
an HTML5 (inaudible) cheat sheet so I will
stop nagging him with my annoying questions.
And I'm going to go ahead and download this.
As you can see, it downloads immediately.
And now I can close it. And if I ever wanted
to get back to it, I have to open up the new
file manager that we built into Chrome OS,
which I have already got open in another tab.
And I can just drill into the folder, and
there's the file, double click. Opens instantly.
So it's very simple, very easy to use.
[ Applause ]
>>Kan Liu: Now, of course, we realize people
have a lot of other important data types.
For example, a lot of users have music, media,
movies and so forth that they want to be able
to play on this device as well.
So let's see how that works.
I am going to go back to the file manager,
and here I have got a USB drive full of some
of my favorite music and movies.
I am going to go into the music folder, and
let's just try to open one of these and see
what happens.
It opens immediately in the new media player
we have added as well.
It's very simple, very easy to use. You can
do basic things. Skip, pause, and you can
even create new play lists and so forth, but
now let's try a video.
So let's go back. And I've got here a bunch
of movie trailers of some of my favorite movies,
but I have also got a Chrome versus potato
gun video which I am very, very excited about
because, let's face it, who doesn't like potato
guns; right?
So let's watch this.
Now, again, it opens immediately in the media
player in the panel form factor, so I can
now go back to checking my e-mail or reading
news or whatever while I continue to watch.
Of course, if I wanted to focus purely on
the video I can easily full-screen it as well.
So let's watch this a second.
So as you can see, as awesome as potato guns
are, they are clearly no match for Chrome.
One of the trends we are seeing is more and
more users are starting to move to online
media consumption. So they are streaming their
content directly from Web services. For example,
yesterday we launched two great services,
movie rentals and Google music beta, which
all work seamlessly on this device as well,
because again, it's just the Web.
Now, of course all of your other favorite
online services like Hulu or Amazon or even
Netflix, which we have been working closely
with, will also just work out of the box.
And same with your music, your MOG, your Pandora
and so forth.
[ Applause ]
>>Kan Liu: Now, another important media type
that a lot of users have today is photos.
In very common-use cases, you are at an event,
maybe I/O, maybe a birthday, maybe a party
of some sort and you take a whole bunch of
photos that you want to be able to share with
your friends. So how does that work on Chrome
OS?
I have got here an SD card full of photos
I took at my daughter's recent birth that
I am very excited to share it with friends.
So I am just going to go ahead and plug it
in.
And now because Chromebooks are cloud devices,
we wanted to make it really easy, really seamless
for users to get their files, their important
data directly into the cloud so they can have
it accessible to them from anywhere as well
as easily share those with other people.
So as you can see, it's automatically opened
up as a new file manager directly in the SD
card. So I can start clicking through all
my photos. I can preview them, select a bunch,
and play a slide show if I wanted to. But
most importantly for me, I just want to get
these in the cloud as soon as possible so
I can share it with some of my friends who
came over to visit.
Now, because I'm a Picasa user, I have gone
ahead and installed the Picasa Web app from
the Chrome Web Store. And by doing so, the
app has actually registered itself as a local
file handler for image file types on this
device.
So now when I select three photos, a new contextual
button pops up that sent to Picasa directly
in line with file manager. So I am going to
go ahead and click this and I can create an
album. Say baby and friends. Let's make this
private, and upload.
And immediately it starts uploading the background,
so I can now go back, continue checking my
e-mail, browsing around the Web. And when
it's done it will tell me and give me a link
to view it online.
And there it is. Very fast, very easy and
now I am ready to share with the world.
[ Applause ]
>>Kan Liu: Now, of course, this works with
other data types as well. For example, your
documents, your presentations, your spreadsheets
and so forth. So let's go back, and here I
have a doc that I have been working on for
Google I/O that I want to share with my friends.
And again, because I am a Google docs user,
I have already installed the Google docs app,
and it's registered itself as a file handler
for doc types.
So I am going to go ahead and click open with
google docs, upload, and I am done.
It's already in the cloud. Now, the best part
is we've built these APIs directly into the
platform so that any Web app can leverage
these same APIs to build the same great experience
for all their users, too.
For example, we have been working with Box.net,
one of the leading online storage providers,
to build the same great app for their users
so they can seamlessly upload docs and file
it directly into Box.
So let me show you how that works. I've got
a PDF here, I've got a button that says "Save
to Box.net," and I am going to click it and,
bam, it's in the cloud already.
I'm ready to go to Box.net and share this
with others.
It's just that simple.
[ Applause ]
>>Kan Liu: And of course working with a lot
of other service providers as well, like Dropbox,
for example, to build the same great experience
for them. And the best part is this is actually
really, really easy to use, or to build apps
on. It literally took Box.net less than one
weekend leveraging their existing upload APIs
and some of our new file extension APIs to
build this app.
So you can imagine in the future, any user
should be able to take an image from their
SD card and open it directly in an online
photo editor. Or if someone sends me a CAD
file I should be able to open that directly
in Tinkercad.
We are really trying to open up the world
of your offline files to the Web so that any
Web app can actually register themselves and
handle your local files.
And so it's our hope that you, as Web app
developers, as Web service writers, will leverage
these same APIs to create the exact same experience
and seamless experience for all your users
as well.
And with that, I'm going to hand it back to
Sundar.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Thank you, Kan. I'm personally
very, very excited by the file extension APIs.
The cloud has more storage than any single
computer, and so we really want to make it
possible for users to store their important
data in the cloud and access them anytime,
anywhere.
I can't wait to see the interesting use cases
you all write on top of these APIs.
So we have been working hard to address the
important use cases. Another important use
case is the ability to use Chromebooks while
you are disconnected.
So we worked hard to make many, many important
applications available offline.
Three of the most important applications which
users have requested us to bring offline are
Gmail, Google Calendar, and Google docs.
We are all using internally offline versions
of these applications and they will all be
available for Chromebook users this summer.
Already today there are hundreds of applications
on the Chrome Web Store which work offline.
New York Times, USA Today, Huffington Post,
Sports Illustrated. You should check it out.
They work seamlessly offline, and almost all
the games, they use package resources and
they work offline in the browser today in
the Chrome Web Store.
Angry Birds, which you saw earlier, works
offline as well.
We also realize it's a very connected world
which is why we brought in seamless connectivity
with built-in 3G as well.
So we have been working to complete this experience.
Back in December we told you we were working
with some of the leading partners in the world
to bring Chromebooks to market. We are working
with Samsung and Acer, two of the leading
companies in the world. Intel powers Chromebooks
with their great processors, and Verizon in
the U.S. with the Gobi modem has incredible
connectivity, and I have been using this app.
In fact, the connectivity piece of Chromebooks,
we received such great feedback during the
pilot program, we worked internationally to
partner with leading carriers all over the
world to make the same option available for
Chromebooks internationally.
So let's take a look at first Chromebooks.
The first Chromebook is from Samsung. Samsung
is the world's leading consumer electronics
manufacturer. They worked with us very closely
to design a Chromebook optimized for Web usage.
It has a 12.1 inch display. It looks great.
It's 300 net display and the Web looks great
on it.
It has all-day battery usage, so you literally
have used it for many days now, you don't
run out of battery while you use it during
the day.
It comes in Wi-Fi as well as the built-in
3G option from Verizon in the U.S. and other
carriers internationally.
And it's available in two colors.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sundar Pichai: The second Chrome book is
from Acer. Acer is the world's leading PC
manufacturer, and they work to come up with
a new Chromebook which is much more portable.
So it has 11.6 inch screen, so it's easy to
carry around. It's a full HD display, but
they worked to fit in a full-size keyboard
so you can easily carry it around and be very,
very productive on this machine.
It's again available in Wi-Fi and 3G.
We just want to give you a sneak preview.
Our partners will be holding events to announce
more details. I should mention that the Samsung
device will be priced at $429 for the Wi-Fi
option. With the built-in 3G option, it is
$499 in the United States.
The Acer device, it's an incredible value.
It's priced starting at $349 and up.
So when will they be available?
On June 15th, we have worked with two of the
leading online retailers in the U.S., Amazon.com
and Best Buy.com so they will be available
for consumers to order on June 15th.
In addition architects the same time they
will be available in six more countries: UK,
France, Germany, Netherlands, Spain and Italy.
In each of these countries, they will be available
through leading online retailers and will
have 3G options from the top carriers in those
countries.
We really hope you get a chance to try out
these devices. For folks like you, we realize
these devices are designed to be very, very
simple to use, so hopefully you can share
with your family members. Like a lot of us,
I'm sure you all get asked to troubleshoot
these devices all the time, so hopefully when
you visit Thanksgiving next time, you get
to eat more Turkey and watch more football.
Of course, as you developers, we want to make
sure you can completely jailbreak these devices.
So my partners may not want to say it, but
these devices have full jail-breaking mode
built in, and you can play around with the
kernel all you want.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Be another group which suffers
from the same complexity in computing are
businesses and educational institutions. Schools.
Let's take a brief look at what their world
looks like.
In most companies today, the IP infrastructure
is so complicated, they actually have a hard
time even accounting for the layers and layers
of software they have within their companies.
In fact, it is so difficult to upgrade operating
systems, over 50% of the companies are still
running Windows XP.
This morning I checked in Wikipedia, Windows
XP was launched in 2001, ten years ago, so
most companies have such a hard time upgrading
their operating systems. It is very, very
costly to do so.
Meanwhile, usage patterns have changed dramatically.
Ten years ago, people used to use desktops.
Today, most users use laptops. They take it
in and out of the enterprise firewall. They're
always connected. The security surface area
is really challenging for I.T. administrators
to manage.
All this adds up as costs for companies. If
you just do a rough survey, most companies
spend starting from 3,000 to high thousands
of dollars per computer per year when they
deploy a PC environment. So it's really complicated.
There is good news. CIOs and I.T. administrators
are well on their way to move things towards
the cloud. Cloud computing is real and big
in the enterprise.
So if you look at it, even many traditional
applications are already moving to the cloud.
Companies like SAP, SalesForce.com, are pioneering
this movement, so you can now, within companies,
use all of them as Web applications.
In addition, many companies are deploying
desktop virtualization. So they are taking
the visual applications and bringing them
through a browser front end to their users.
So for Chromebooks, we have partnered with
two of the leading retailers in the space,
Citrix and VMware, to make sure the same applications
are available in Chromebooks through the browser.
When we launched the Cr-48 pilot program,
we had over 50,000 companies apply to test
Chromebooks. We have deployed them in hundreds
of companies and thousands of devices.
Here are a few examples.
Intercontinental Hotels. They have hundreds
of call service agents in distributed locations.
They have been piloting Chromebooks to great
results.
A more classic example is Jason's Deli. They
have hundreds of retail store locations all
over the U.S. It is so cost-prohibitive for
them that in many stores, all store managers
share one Windows laptop in the back of the
store.
So we took a few stores, deployed Chromebooks.
Every store manager gets one. They've been
able to seamlessly manage the deployment.
We have tested this with governmental institutions.
The city of Orlando, if you go there, you
will find Chromebooks in offices, in some
cases inside fire trucks, and in some cases,
even on the streets.
In fact, the only piece of feedback they've
had is people have asked for more power cards,
because they are using them everywhere. So
this is really, really easy to use.
We did -- we spent four months talking to
over 400 companies and had an in-depth survey
of where the Chromebooks are applicable. Almost
all companies said that the combination of
Web applications and desktop virtualization,
they can migrate 75% of their users today
to Chromebooks.
So we want to make it available to them, the
same two Chromebooks which are available for
consumers will be available for businesses
as well.
In addition, when we talked with them, not
everyone has a mobile use case. For example,
in retail store locations, they want a box
from which they can drive large monitors.
Google engineers wanted the same thing as
well. They wanted a box from which they can
drive large monitors. We are working on a
Chromebooks as well which we think will be
ideal for many, many companies.
So how will we offer this?
As I said earlier, the device is only one
part of the cost.
Most of the expenses are in management and
administration. So we worked to design a Web
console so just from a Web page, I.T. administrators
can centrally manage all Chromebooks. They
can add and remove users. They can install
apps, remove applications, have centralized
group policy settings for their entire employee
base. It's dead simple to manage.
We want to make it really easy for them to
manage their computing, so we have an end-to-end
offering. We call this Chromebooks for Business.
For the first time, it is software and hardware
as a service, packaged together.
So what do companies get? They get the devices,
they get Chromebooks. You get a centralized
Web console. You get full support. You get
warranty and replacements. So if your device
breaks down, we ship you a new device. And
when the hardware life cycle is over, we automatically
upgrade you to the next generation Chromebook.
All for a convenient monthly price of $28
per user.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: Software and hardware as
a service.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: We think this can fundamentally
change the way people use computing in companies.
Another area which we passionately care about
is schools. It's incredible that in today's
age, most schools can't provide computers
for their students. Again, the reasons are
the same. You can go and buy a cheap PC, but
it's impossible -- we have talked to every
school -- it's impossible to manage a deployment
of a thousand PCs in a cost-effective manner.
They just cannot afford it.
So we want to make it possible for every student
to have a computer in schools as well.
So we worked with our partners, and Chromebooks
for Education is priced at $20 per user for
schools and governmental institutions.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So when are these available?
Just like for consumers, starting June 15th,
Chromebooks are available for companies and
schools and governments. You can order them
directly from Google, and they're available
in the same seven countries.
Both consumers and businesses can go and find
all the information they want at google.com/Chromebook.
Many of us, as we were working on the project,
we were asked to describe what Chromebooks
are. And I'm sure a lot of you will get asked
the same question as well.
So to help that, we have put together a little
something which describes what Chromebooks
are.
Let's take a look.
[ Video. ]
>>Video: This is a laptop. This is a computer.
This has the Web. That's weird.
Okay. So it's the Web. There are no programs?
So there's nothing to start up?
Then how do I do stuff?
There's no messy desktop?
So no rolling hills of green.
[ Laughter ]
>>Video: Can I use it anywhere?
On a unicycle?
My calendars, e-mails, documents? Everything
can be saved to the Web.
That's crazy. So I can throw this thing into
a river, and I won't lose my stuff?
[ Laughter ]
>>Video: It doesn't need virus protection?
What about annoying updates?
Or patches? Or patches for the patches?
So it gets better in realtime.
I wonder if people are ready for this. It's
kind of a new thought.
[ Video concludes. ]
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: We think users are really
ready for this, so we want to make sure we
make them available. And we are incredibly
excited about getting them to test this out.
The Web is what you make of it. Many of you
in the audience here are -- really helped
Chrome get early traction and get the word
out to our users. So we hope you all get a
chance to try out Chromebooks and help spread
the word as well.
In fact, which is why --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: -- we want to make sure every
I/O attendee gets a free Chromebook. These
are --
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: These are available on June
15th. We will send you an e-mail with details
so that you can claim your Chromebook very,
very soon.
The Web is the most amazing platform --
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: The Web is the most amazing
platform, development platform, in our lifetimes.
The future of the Web is in the hands of a
lot of you in the audience. We hope you continue
to write great applications and the Web is
what you make of it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]